[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 12 mars début d'une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv à 60,18 bienvenue dans cette
édition
tout de suite les titres de ce set 8
journal neuf mois qu'ils sont entrés à
l'assemblée nationale six députés du
parti présidentiel de la république en
marge se réunissait ce matin à elancourt
et devant la presse les parlementaires
ont dressé le bilan de leurs activités à
la chambre et dans leur circonscription
respective les détails à suivre
un périple de plus de cinq mille six
cents kilomètres à travers la mongolie
les états unis et la france c'est la
distance parcourue l'été dernier à vélo
et à pied par le major patrick bonnaud
il a relevé ce défi fou en 33 jours pour
les orphelins de la police
vendredi le comité olympique des
yvelines l'a récompensé pour son action
patrick bonnot est notre invité et puis
une journée entièrement dédiée aux arts
martiaux à montigny le bretonneux elle
s'est déroulée samedi dernier à
l'initiative des associations de la
ville notamment initiation au karaté
taekwondo ou encore aïkido étaient au
programme
autres invités de ce journal mathilde
andrew hayes secrétaire départemental du
front national des yvelines elle viendra
parler avec nous du congrès de
refondation qui se tenait à lille ce
week end où a été est notamment évoqué
le changement de nom pour le parti c'est
à suivre une aide de 12 millions d'euros
sur trois ans soutien financier de la
région ile de france au parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
un contrat triennal sur la période 2018
2020 il a été signé à chevreuse samedi
en prêts en partenariat avec l'état
c'était en présence vous le voyez de la
présidente de la région valérie pécresse
le coup de pouce au territoire de 50 et
une commune va concerner plusieurs
domaines est la sauvegarde des commerces
de proximité le développement des
énergies renouvelables la valorisation
du patrimoine ou encore l'agriculture
locale écoutez ces réactions collectées
au micro de mélanie poker c'est tout à
fait déterminant le conseil régional
c'est à peu près la moitié du
financement total du parc
et donc pour nous c'est le partenaire
numéro un et donc le fait que la région
s'engage à nouveau dans un contrat sur
plusieurs années c'est pour nous à la
fois une sécurité financière et surtout
ça nous donne de la visibilité sur les
politiques que nous voulons mener à long
terme
ça permettra d'avoir des procédures
beaucoup plus rapide
ça permettra aussi de développer une
vraie ambition régionale sur les parcs
qui sont les laboratoires en matière
d'énergies renouvelables en matière de
circuits courts agricoles en matière
d'éco d'éco construction et déco
urbanisme en matière de transports
propres
bref les parcs vont devenir nos
laboratoires pour qu'on puisse vivre à
la campagne près de paris je vous en
parlais dans les titres et six députés
de la république heures marche ont tenu
une conférence de presse ce lundi matin
à elancourt
l'occasion pour eux de faire un point
sur leur activité à l'assemblée
nationale et dans leur circonscription
ils ont notamment évoqué les questions
de sécurité avec le dispositif de la
police de sécurité du quotidien elle les
précisions de nicolas d'andrus neuf mois
à l'assemblée nationale et les réformes
s'enchaînent pour les députés yves
binois de la république en marche c'est
le cas de la police de sécurité du
quotidien avec trappe reconnus comme
territoires de reconquête républicaine
par le ministre de l'intérieur
le commissariat de la ville va
accueillir entre 15 et 30 policiers
supplémentaires pour le moment
effectivement nous réfléchissons encore
sur la façon dont ils vont intervenir
mais l'idée vraiment première delà du
déploiement de ces forces là c'est de
rétablir un lien entre la police la
police et la population dans les
yvelines concrètement notamment dans les
territoires ruraux
on va voir ce qu'on appelle un groupe de
contact de la gendarmerie à montfort
l'amaury donc au coeur du sud des
yvelines de manière à renforcer le lien
de proximité qui existe entre nos
gendarmes et la population via des
moyens supplémentaires
autre point abordé les emplois francs
objectif favoriser l'embauché de
personnes issues de quartiers populaires
et lutter contre la discrimination à
l'embauché
un dispositif expérimenté dans le val
d'oise notamment et qui pourrait être
étendue jusqu'à saint quentin en
yvelines
nous sommes en train de travailler que
le préfet d'île de france elle préfet
des yvelines est d'ailleurs au courant
de cette expérimentation pour voir
comment des associations par exemple
comme face
78 déjà font un travail extrêmement
important de mise en relation entre les
entreprises et les jeunes issus des
quartiers ou qui n'ont pas de réseau
tout simplement on compare un réseau
professionnel étendu pour industrialiser
ce dispositif couvrir beaucoup plus de
jeunes à l'échelle de l'ensemble de
saint quentin en yvelines
donc on y verra clair d'ici quelques
semaines sur le dispositif précis les
députés la république en marge des
yvelines seront aussi engagés sur
d'autres dossiers la loi asile
immigration ou encore la réforme
constitutionnelle
on continue de parler politique avec une
invitée qui m'a a rejoint un plateau
mathilde endroit bon soir dans ça vous
êtes la secrétaire départemental du
front national des yvelines alors votre
parti tenait ce week end à lille son
congrès de refondation volonté exprimée
on va en parler dans un instant assez
changé le nom du front national déjà une
réaction peut-être sur le sujet que l'on
vient de voir les députés la république
en marge qui ont dressé ce matin leur
bilan quel regard vous portez sur ces
neuf premiers mois des députés zibinoh à
l'assemblée nationale une volonté
affichée avant leur élection
réformer les pratiques politiques est ce
que le défi est relevé selon vous non
pas du tout parce qu'après justement
assure tendance sur l'honnêteté nos
députés je crois que le fait d'avoir un
casier judiciaire vierge ne fait plus
partie des conditions justement pour
être éligible par ailleurs au bond les
députés la république en marche je pense
que c'est bien le garder d'ailleurs
cette appellation les députés parce que
aucune personnalité ne sort si ce n'est
enfin vraiment pour dans le suivisme
total derrière le gouvernement
et même ce gouvernement lui-même suivi
derrière macron donc on a rarement vu un
gouvernement qui promettait aux
tourneurs donnant autant de finalement
de la négation du des idées députés donc
il n'en des députés que le titre mais
certainement pas l'exercice à mon avis
alors vous êtes venus pour parler de
votre parti le front national qui se
réunissait donc ce week-end en congrès à
lille le parti va changer de nom c'est
la principale information à retenir
marine le pen qui a été aussi réélu pour
un troisième mandat à la tête du front
national à l'unanimité
c'est une bonne décision selon vous de
de conserver marine le pen à la barre du
front national où finalement oui on peut
le rappeler après un second tour de la
présidentielle ratée ce que c'était une
bonne décision quand même apprendre de
confirmer marine le pen a second tour
raté mais en même temps qu'ils avaient
jamais rassemblé autant de personnes
derrière la bannière du front national
est derrière marine le pen je pense
qu'on contraire marine le pen et que la
personne qui a fait vraiment fait faire
un bond au front national
maintenant le tout est de 2 alors
vraiment de faire une réussite de faire
de transformer le front national qui
était parti pour d'opposition en
désormais un parti de gouvernement et je
pense que là ce nom c'est plus que de la
cosmétique en fait c'est plus qu'un nom
c'est vraiment avoir le mode
rassemblement est intéressant parce que
je pense qu'il donne autant l'état
d'esprit dans lequel elle se trouve
marine le pen elle-même l'ensemble des
personnes qui animent son parti donc
même mois et aussi une nouvelle
ça donne beaucoup de choses aussi sur
l'évolution co structurelles qu'on peut
avoir dans l'option du parti ce
changement dans le noir pendant un
instant une décision prise également
avec le vote des nouveaux statuts du
parti c'est la suppression de la
fonction de président d'honneur jean
marie le pen n'est donc plus le
président d'honneur du mouvement qu'il a
fondé c'est un choix qui met fin selon
vous à à la guerre intestine au sein du
parti ou au contraire ça va ça ne risque
pas au contraire de scinder les
partisans pro jean marie le pen et pro
marine le pen faut savoir qu'avec la vie
l'arrivée de marine le pen les adhérents
étaient à 80 % des nouveaux adhérents
donc clairement en fait cette histoire
de jean marie le pen est une appartient
au passé
donc non aucune polémique c'est même un
sujet qui n'a pas du tout été évoquées
ce week-end et pour avoir fait le tour
des fédérations en tant qu'ambassadrice
de la refondation en ile de france
hormis une des questions clairement dans
jean marie le pen est une page tournée
les gens veulent juste maintenant avoir
un parti fonctionnel efficace et arriver
enfin à la victoire tu poses les
français vous n'avez donc informations
central de ce congrès un la volonté
affichée de change et non le front
national devrait devenir le
rassemblement national le choix sera
soumis au vote des militants par
correspondance donner un nouveau nom au
front national c'était primordial oui
pour insuffler peut-être un nouveau
souffle au mouvement comme je vous
disais voilà ça donne ça dénote autant
notre état d'esprit en ce moment comme
le font qu'on vous donnez vraiment ce à
ce parti c'est parti c'est un parti de
gouvernement donc un parti qui a
réfléchi sur la manière de se structurer
aussi bien au niveau sur les questions
européennes
oui ce moment il ya un grand travail de
rédaction des traités de réflexion sur
la diplomatie pour enfin construire
l'union des nations européennes
on est à un an des élections européennes
voilà je me donne un objectif évidemment
et ce sera un projet comportera dans un
an et un peut-être un peu moins puisque
la commun la campagne commencera
certainement plus tôt mais est aussi
voilà le but du jeu étant de s'organiser
sur le fond la forme le fonctionnement
donc je pense que changer de nom était
aussi une manière de faire sauter ce
verrou psychologique des comme dit
marine le pen ya des gens qui sont
sincèrement rebutés par l'image
véhiculée par ce nom par l'historique de
ce parti le but du jeu est de montrer
qu'on nous sommes tout à fait en
capacité de les entendre et de les
accueillir parce que notre but du jeu
comme le nom l'indiqué on veut
rassembler tous ceux tous les amoureux
de la france où les amoureux de la
nation française et donc non je trouve
que c'est une bonne phase que nous
amorçons la rend ce moment là justement
rassemblement national est ce que ça ça
ouvre la voix à droite des alliances
peut-être une nouvelle fois avec nicolas
dupont aignan comme ça s'est passé
pendant le pendant l'élection
présidentielle le parti debout la france
de nicolas dupont aignan peut-être même
le parti des républicains on sait qu'un
ancien ministre thierry mariani est lui
favorable à une alliance avec le front
national c'est ça ouvre aussi la voie à
des alliances
oui évidemment parce que c'est
l'objectif maintenant il faut
il a la structuration mon avis du
paysage politique se fait vraiment entre
les amoureux de la nation française est
ce qu ont décidé d'avoir le monde comme
terrain de jeu donc nous nous défendrons
la france nous pensons que c'est un
échelon l'échelon national et un échelon
pertinent pour défendre nos concitoyens
et nous pensons que c'est aussi un
échelon pertinent pour l'ensemble des
nations européennes d'ailleurs mai
et donc il fallait juste organiser comme
tel et maintenant balayé un peu ce
système de partis qui d'ailleurs a été
partiellement balayé par l'arrivée de
monsieur mâcon cas clarifier en même
temps le jeu entre beau d'avoir entre
les nationaux ceux qui auraient des fins
de la nation et je les mondialistes qui
sont pour un déracinement total et
global à tous les niveaux social à
l'échelle du travail même de notre
quotidien ou des migrations qui
finalement ne déstabilise énormément sur
de nombreux plans ce sera ma dernière
question je rappelle que vous êtes à la
tête du front national des yvelines
changer non est ce qu'au niveau local ça
change concrètement les choses ou pas du
tout changé l'appellation maintenant du
responsable départemental et délégué
départemental je trouve ça intéressant
parce que c'est bien la preuve qu' une
grande confiance aussi sur les personnes
de terrain on était présente tous
derrière marine le pen lors de son
discours hier et on a vraiment
délégation de politique ce truc aussi
sur le niveau de la structure si bien
sûr est-ce que sur le fond sur les déos
logis donc je pense que c'est vraiment
nous faire confiance et l'échelon local
devient vraiment très très important
pour marine le pen
merci martin andrew et d'avoir été avec
nous donc des lisiers départementales
n'ont pu secrétaire départemental du
front national des urines merci d'avoir
été avec nous c'est une idée théorisée
par un sociologue américain dans les
années 1930 la méthode à linz qui vise à
mobiliser les populations à des
quartiers populaires en unissant donc
les populations
en unissant la colère de ces populations
une méthode qui soit que souhaite
appliquer la france insoumise dans le
quartier castiglione del lago attrape
samedi quelques militants rencontré des
habitants pour appuyer leur démarche ces
derniers sont en conflit depuis
plusieurs années avec le bailleur social
efidis et les appartements ne serait pas
assez chauffer l'hiver à cause d'une
mauvaise isolation une pétition est
signée par tous les résidents a été
remis aux bailleurs les habitants du
quartier sont sur le point de créer un
collectif pour peser face à efidis on
referme cette page politique avec une
réunion publique organisée vendredi par
le mouvement génération le mouvement de
benoît hamon créé il ya huit mois a
convié à soutien et curieux aux
clayes-sous-bois un rassemblement autour
de l'actualité sur le thème migratoire
un projet de loi était présenté fin
février par le gouvernement il est
fortement a critiqué à gauche pour son
volet est trop répressif explications
avec nicolas landry et nicolas
kirillovitch dans les yvelines le
mouvement génération est en territoire
connu mais loin d'être conquis ancienne
terre d'élection de benoît hamon le
mouvement cherche à s'implanter et pour
y parvenir il faut d'abord séduire des
électeurs de gauche
encore sonnés après la suite des
défaites électorales
quel regard vous portez justement sur ce
mouvement naissant
je ne connais pas trop alors justement
j'ai peut-être d'en savoir plus ce soir
je militerai pour rassemblement des
gauches en fait un lap à gauche c'est du
très dispersé si je peux vrai dans ce
domaine c'est ce c'est mon voeu marqueur
emblématique pour la gauche le mouvement
génération avait choisi d'évoquer ce
soir là la thématique migratoire un
sujet où les différences avec le
gouvernement sont nombreuses et faciles
à trouver une des vocations du mouvement
générations cde d'apporter un regard
différent sur la manière dont on doit
être bienveillant auprès d'eux
concitoyens qu'ils soient micro pas
pareils aux invités de cette réunion
publique le maire de grande synthe dans
le nord est venu témoigner de son
expérience pense qu'il faut rétablir des
chiffres il faut rétablir des réalités
est ce que j'ai vécu à 45 ans en
accueillant 2500 exilé sur le territoire
de la ville en ouvrant un camp pour 1300
d'entre eux montrent que c'est possible
de le faire et donc on dédramatise ont
fait tomber tous les fantasmes qu'il ya
autour de cet accueil des réfugiés
le projet de loi asile et immigration
sera débattu en avril à l'assemblée
nationale c'est alors la france
insoumise qui devrait porter la voix de
l'opposition dans l'hémicycle elle 5633
kilomètres réalisés à vélo et en course
à pied en 33 jours un défi fou au profit
des enfants orphelins de la police
relevé par le major patrick bonneau qui
étaient avec leur plateau un bon soir
oui bonsoir à vous êtes policier au
commissariat de plaisir alors ce défi
fou vous l'avez conclu en france en
passant par la mongolie les états unis
et c'était l'été dernier vendredi le
comité olympique et sportif des yvelines
vous a remis un éclat olympique pour
cette action c'était donc à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles
première question pourquoi se lancer
dans cette aventure pourquoi finalement
aider ces enfants de vos collègues
disparus
au départ c'était parti sur un défi
sportif
donc j'ai eu connaissance qu'il y avait
une course de 333 km dans le désert de
gobi qui avait lieu donc
j'avais envie de la faire parce que je
vais déjà participé dans des courses
dans plusieurs des airs différents donc
je vais découvrir désert de gobi et j'ai
voulu enchaîner et pendant mon
entraînement un joueur en vélo j'ai
pensé à tous les collègues qui a été
victime un petit peu de ce qu'on vit de
ce qu'on est au courant mais également
de deux accidents pendant le service et
qu'il essaie d heure fola et je me suis
mis à pleurer sur mon vélo je me suis
dit je peux pas faire ça pour moi tout
seul simplement pour le défi il faut que
faut que mes coups de pédales et mais
pas soit utile donc j'ai lancé une
collecte via facebook et pour récolter
des dons pour les orphelins de la police
nationale justement j'allais vous
demandez 1800 euros collectés au total
pendant ce défi ça et ça été récoltés
viennent une collecte sur facebook c'est
ça alors là l'information est passée sur
facebook et l'échec est arrivé
directement au commissariat à l'ordre de
leur folie là et on a récolté donc 1800
euros est alors un périple de 33 jours
qui a été très difficile on va en parler
dans un instant comment ça s'est préparé
vous l'avez dit vous êtes un sportif
dans l'âme et comment on est préparé un
périple de beau temps de kilomètres
finalement on m'a déjà cessé allez au
boulot en vélo donc ses 25 km de vélo
aller 25 km autour de philippe perret de
l'eredivisie oui près de près du
perray-en-yvelines d'accord et pour
aller au commissariat de plaisir et puis
le midi ben ses courses à pied ou vélo
donc voilà c'est si ça c'est dur de
sport par jour
le week-end en génie par semaine par
dont le week-end c'était des sorties de
deux vélos de 150 200 km d'accord et
puis ben et puis surtout la volonté quoi
à la volonté d'aller au bout et avant
tout il fallait vraiment que je prenne
mes billets d'avion parce que pour être
sûr de partir parce que il ya plein de
doutes qui se greffe sur pendant la
préparation
donc une fois qu'on a les billets
d'avion après on fait plus vite ou alors
vous en ai dit de me faisais choisi la
mongolie pour cette course dans le
désert de gobi les états unis pourquoi
ben c'était un rêve également c'était en
fin de compte des courses de cete 333 km
et des courses de cette distance là j'en
avais déjà fait donc pour moi c'était
pas vraiment relever un défi
donc il fallait que je fasse autre chose
et je me suis plutôt que de revenir vers
l'ouest en partant de mongolie je vais
partir vers l'est et puis je suis allé à
los angeles j'ai fait los angeles new
york en vélo c'était un rêve d'enfant
donc que j'ai réalisé en vélo sur la
route 66 ce qu'on peut penser on peut la
parcourir plus volontiers à moto vous
souhaitez à vélo oui j'ai rencontré
quelques biker alors les bikers des
alliés ou crazy humaine parce que il est
très très chaud dans les déserts
notamment donc la route 66 on la voit
surtout dans le désert du nevada de
l'arizona et mais c'était oui c'était un
vélo c'était un gros défi ouais alors on
revient sur les étapes vous avez parlé
un petit peu de cette étape sur la route
66 les 333 km en mongolie comment ça
s'est déroulé bien bien bien
on était trente coureurs donc c'était
basé sur une course
donc on est parti à 30 coureurs qui
venaient principalement de france mais
aussi d'europe
et puis ben le but c'était d'avancer le
plus vite possible quoi ses 333 km
non-stop c'est un départ une arrivée un
ravitaillement tous les 25 km dans des
lieux dans des yourtes way et puis ben
voilà c'est premier arrivé qui gagne
donc faut limiter le sommet il faut faut
gérer les bobos et puis qu'on arrive au
bout
plein de choses à gérer poursuit temps
suit donc avec cette traversée d'ouest
en est des états unis los angeles à new
york en empruntant une grande partie du
voyage la mythique route 66 à vélo une
difficulté non des moindres c'est la
chaleur des températures qu'on pu monter
jusqu'à 50 degrés comment comment gèrent
cet aspect là comment vous avez pu gérer
cet aspect là bas c'était ingérable
c'était ingérable bon moi je m'étais
basé quand même sûr je vais 19 jours
pour faire le périple donc ça faisait à
peu près 250 km par jour et il est 50
degrés oui mais en vélo je prenais
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs que par exemple
je mettais des glaçons dans mon bidon et
un quart d'heure après c'était d'eau
chaude donc c'était vraiment ingérable
donc je n'avais pas pensé au lieu de
fermer 250 km par jour
lens est plus que 150 s'est déroulée la
nuit mais j'avais donc une assistance
j'avais un ami qui faisait mon
assistance et qui m'a beaucoup aidé pour
arriver au bout et qui lui ben la nuit
avait besoin de dormir c'était très
difficile de suivre un vélo à 25 ou 30
km heure donc on a décidé très peu roulé
la nuit et puis ben il faut je suis
resté une semaine dans les déserts et
une fois les déserts passé le colorado
et laverdure là j'ai pu enchaîner et
faire des étapes de environ 280 km par
jour et d'ailleurs ça vous a pas empêché
de boucler finalement ce parcours avec
un jour d'avancé est arrivé à new york
avec un jour d'avancé
oui ben j'avais mon avion à prendre les
billets d'avion étaient pris donc
c'était soit
j'arrêtais un vent et puis je finissais
en voiture mais c'est pour moi c'était
inimaginable soit bunge appuyer sur les
pédales et puis bon faut dire que j'ai
été énormément suivi mange pas très
communicative sur facebook mais je les
fais un petit peu j'étais énormément
suivi et ça m'a donné beaucoup de baume
au coeur
de retour en france vous avez rendu
visite à votre famille à lyon et là
c'est pas terminé vous avez décidé de
rentrer en course à pied de lyon jusque
jusque dans les yvelines est ce que
c'était prévu cette dernière étape la
base ben à la base mon tout s'est
construit petit à petit d'abord désert
de gobi après je me suis dit pourquoi
pas les états unis et puis je me suis
dit mais pourquoi pas je cours sur le
continent asiatique sur le continent
américain et je viens en francs ne
continent européen je fais rien donc je
vais aller faire la bise à ma mère et
puis je vais rentrer à pied de lyon
parce que je suis originaire de lyon est
donc je savais que ce serait l'épreuve
la plus difficile et les pions plancher
dès les premiers kilomètres c'est ça
votre 40 km en fait j'ai dû subi un gros
orage
donc j'étais vraiment un autonomie
j'avais pris que deux paires de
chaussettes de slips de t-shirts et
voilà pour pour faire le parcours est
lavé au fur et à mesure et en fin de
compte mes pieds se sont dégradés avec
tous les échauffements dès que j'avais
subi aux états unis
et puis ben on pousse sur en poule après
j'avais plus de pouls sous les pieds
donc j'avais du mal à avancer et pour
pouvoir avancer
je dormais plus dernière question donc
33 jours de périple le 34e on peut se
dire repos bien mérité non vous êtes
vous retourner directement au travail
dès le 34e jour à plaisir mais pas le
choix et mais pas le choix il fallait y
aller un peu fou ouais mais bon des
choses folles c'est bien il faut
continuer à en faire
merci major patrick gauneau d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que le comité
olympique et sportif des yvelines vous a
remis un éclat olympique pour cette
action dont on a parlé et ce périple les
téléspectateurs peuvent le revoir leurs
vivres sur votre page facebook
eurasia mme erika hess à sa fiche en bas
de l'écran merci d'avoir été avec toc un
celi autre action celle ci en faveur de
l'emploi la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion face yvelines a lancé
vendredi sa nouvelle job academy
deuxième édition avec l'entreprise
sodexo dont le siège est basé à
guyancourt durant quatre mois 28
salariés dont 28 demandeurs d'emploi
vont accompagner donc ces demandes et
emploie 28 salariés vont accompagner 28
demandeurs d'emploi on va y arriver est
le but grâce à ce parrainage c'est de
valoriser les compétences et de
retrouver un travail
un reportage dorer les onze sa fonction
la direction son ancienneté essai audi à
sa c4 c4 chose de pouvoir le retrouver
magali n'aura pas tardé à trouver son
parrain en recherche d'emploi depuis
presque un an elle fait partie des 28
personnes sélectionnées pour cette job
academy
c'est la deuxième année que la société
de restauration et de services sodexo
répond présente
force est de constater qu'à la fin de la
première édition ça s'est super bien
passé avec des retours évidemment des
filhols ça c'est important
très intéressant mais aussi des parrains
et des marraines et parrains et
marraines se sont pris au jeu
la particularité qu'on a c'est vraiment
de faire des binômes individuelles et
des job academy qui sont surtout sur du
collectif mais nous on tient vraiment à
ce que un parent accompagnant un filleul
durant quatre mois accompagnement et
coaching
voilà ce qui attend les binômes au cours
des prochains mois une action qui permet
notamment aux salariés de données
d'échanger et de se rendre utile
j'essaierai d'apporter mon vécu en
termes de recherche d'emploi et la façon
aussi de l'entretien mais réseau pour
en faire profiter
mon filleul je croise les doigts
j'espère que ça va apporter plein de
choses et si c'est pas dans quatre mois
ça ne s'est pas forcé que ce soit dans
quatre mois mais mais déjà voilà avoir
créé du lien en fait je pense que c'est
ce serait se seront bien parmi les 19
personnes parrainées l'année dernière
par un salarié de sodexo 15 d'entre
elles ont retrouvé un emploi
une table ronde sur le sport féminin
elle était au programme jeudi à 8 mars
au prisme à elancourt à l'occasion de la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes corps sportif au féminin
questionner sur la pratique féminine les
femmes sont de plus en plus présente
dans le sport mais par le ton
aujourd'hui de la même manière à des
équipes féminines et masculines pour y
répondre plusieurs intervenantes de
choix dont la présidente est du comité
d'organisation de l'euro 2018 de
handball féminin en france ça se passe
fin novembre
propos recueillis par nicolas landry et
patrick jacques de dixmude
je dirais que le sport féminin progresse
bien dire qu'il est à sa juste place
pas encore mais il va il va tendre vers
la place qu'il mérite dans le sens où on
parlera autant des hommes que des femmes
sportives et sportifs et je pense que
progressivement on va atteindre ce
niveau là et les femmes vont gagner
véritablement leur place dans le milieu
sportif sport toujours pour refermer ce
journal judo bushido taekwondo ou encore
aïkido tous ces arts martiaux vous
pouviez les découvrir samedi dernier au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny le bretonneux une journée
d'initiation été proposée avec comme
objectif final vous allez le voir ce
reportage de mélanie poké et demi
qu'elle est l'amie dont
les gestes sont encore hésitants mais la
volonté est bien présente karaté bushido
des jeans ou encore aïkido des novices
ont pu tester ce samedi 10 mars une
dizaine d'arts martiaux venus des
contrées asiatiques font que trop bien
j'ai fait avec les jets
ça écoute quoi comme ça pour les combats
je dire les techniques pour apprendre à
se défendre avec les enfants les adultes
se sont également prêtés au jeu
ils ont appris pendant cette journée a
esquivé à contrer ou à maîtriser des
techniques avec l'été clubs locaux on a
essayé le taï shi tzu et ben ça nous a
bien plu puisque on a fait des exercices
au moins 15 différents sur votre ce
qu'une heure on était venus pour essayer
dix minutes un quart d'heure et puis on
est resté j'ai appris quelque chose
aujourd'hui
objectif annoncé de l'événement faire
découvrir les 13 associations d'arts
martiaux de montigny le bretonneux et
surtout convertir les 1000 participants
à leur discipline et à des gens qui ont
pris nos coordonnées
ils vont venir effet ils ont déjà essayé
ici vont venir essayer au sein du club
certains avaient peur parce qu'on leur a
montré beaucoup de technique leur
expliquer que là aujourd'hui c'est une
initiation leur montrer un panel pour
leur faire goûter pour leur donner envie
mais au sein du club on présente
effectivement qu une deux voire trois
techniques maximum pour qu'ils aient le
temps de balancer les approprier les
maîtriser pour convaincre définitivement
les débutants encore un peu hésitant la
journée s'est clôturée par un spectacle
sur les différents arts martiaux et des
mises en scène
l'opération séduction devrait avoir
fonctionné et encore plus d'efforts et
de sueur à suivre ce soir dans le 7-8
sport présentée par michael et demi
d'euros c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi édition reportage à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 belle soirée à
tous
[Musique]